hi this is relate well I guess yeah yes
it is relief I heard you say it is
important to think I heard Jocko say
this too how do you think meaning how do
you talk to yourself do you ask yourself
questions do you think by talking to
others what do you believe is the most
valuable method for becoming a clear
thinker and communicator that's a deep
question I actually think it's pretty
easy to answer it is easy answer I think
I can answer in one word go detach
that's that's that's how I think you you
can't you got to step out you got to
step back
mentally you gotta step back look at
what's going on and think of and that's
where you can think about it that's
where you can figure out what's going on
if you can do that you're there if you
can't do it you don't even know you're
not doing it that's the problem when
you're not detached you don't even know
you're not attached you're in the storm
and you don't even know it that's out
for that's exactly right but I think you
know for people that maybe don't fully
understand what that means right the
this idea of the tattoo which you've
obviously talked a lot about on here and
which is such a key thing for decision
making it's the the I think the key
thing there is is to make sure that
you're not you're not clouded by you
know this emotional attachment to plans
which we often talked about with our
leaders in the SEAL team so I am
emotionally invested in a plan that I
came up with I spent hours or days or
weeks or months you know involved in and
I want that to succeed of course but but
is that you know I gotta have that
realistic assessment and that's what the
detachment really requires is that you
pull yourself not just physically away
you know out of the weeds are to say
okay let me think about this in the
strategic picture but you really you
take away that emotional investment that
you have to to maybe even whether it's a
plan sometimes it's a team member as
well and if you have you know someone
that you just have a close relationship
with that you you know that whether
there are a relative of yours or you had
a long-standing relationship with and
and that maybe you've gotten too close
to them and you can't see that that you
know they become more important than the
mission and they're dragging the rest of
the team down you're not making the call
either tighten them up or let them go if
that's that's the right case so I think
what that really requires is you got
emotionally pull back it's
it's a mental thing to really have a
brutally honest assessment of the
situation that's that's independent from
any kind of previous bias that you might
have had that's interesting there
because even if you know like oh yeah
I'm gonna detach oh not that easy yeah
like yeah go through the motions you
can't be like hey I'm gonna detach I'm
detached right now meanwhile you're just
like I said clouded by the emotional
part that you're like kind of one foot
in emotionally so you're technically not
detached so it doesn't work you know
what else is a good way to think is to
listen you listen to what people are
saying I've been thinking about how
Moore how he said if you listen you know
twice as much you know everything that
you know and you know everything that
the other guy knows yeah that's a great
that's a great thing but if you're
sitting in a you know conversation I
mean from a business perspective if
you're in a meeting and and there's a
conversation going on if you're in the
conversation you're talking you're
adding your piece well then you're
you're not detached you're in it but if
you sit back and you listen and you hear
what's going on you can assemble you
know thoughts better